[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits a podcast where
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time i'm link
and i'm rhett this week at the
roundtable of dim lighting we're going
to be talking about
our relationship to christmas
and how it has evolved over time
as we've evolved as people yeah it's um
it's it's an interesting touch point
it's it's interesting
for me this is kind of an exercise of
looking through the lens of christmas
and seeing my former self
maybe in different stages and then my
current self
is that that's that's how you see this
going yeah i mean
you know this conversation i mean
talking about yeah lord just life
yeah i mean i think i want to talk about
the way that i used to think about
christmas um
and then as i was sort of transitioning
out of
personally considering myself a
christian like what that was like and
then
what it's like today um
and how that and how that continues to
be in process yeah who
this is going to be interesting who
knows where this is going to go
one one quick thing before we move on
though
is it a podcast we're two lifelong
friends or is it the podcast we're two
lifelong friends
i don't listen to any other ones with
two lifelong friends talk about life
really because
i think i've been saying the but i could
have sworn you said uh
oh did i okay i'd like to retract my
uh and replace it with the i don't know
it was very quick
you swallowed it they swallowed it a
little bit it doesn't didn't really know
so i didn't
i mean but i want but you made me think
hold on
is it or the what have i been saying i
think i've been saying the we'll have to
go to the tate do we want to say the
let's say the i might say v i reserve
the right to say thee
back to christmas i mean this year in
particular
in this approaching holiday season
i mean yes we're going to be talking
about christmas
and there's going to be sorry to
interrupt you but you've said two
phrases that make me think of christmas
movies you said the lens of christmas
and i was like that would be a good
christmas movie then you said
back to christmas and i was thinking
about a future like a future
like a time travel movie back to the
future for christmas i should go back to
christmas
for something i really want to make a
christmas movie man we should make a
christmas movie
well the idea we came up with for a
christmas movie it just didn't
it didn't come together what was that
idea it was called um
it was it was about a gift it was about
a gift that you
it was a husband got a gift for his wife
he wanted to get her the perfect gift
it's called the perfect gift
yes and it sure i still think it's a i
think we could update the idea and still
make it i don't think it was a horrible
idea
and we had a we had a role for jeff
goldblum remember that
yeah he was not that he would have ever
said yes no he was attached
i want to make a christmas movie man
cause i even i was you know i got to
make a wreck later on and i was like i'm
going to wreck sort of like an under the
radar christmas movie
i got a great recommendation for
christmas movie it's my favorite movie
of all time yeah we know elf
and uh so i'm not gonna steal that but
i'm not gonna recommend a christmas
movie because
there's just not i mean it's hard to
find the ones that are good
when you end up going very really
quickly to die hard as a christmas movie
which is not a christmas movie it just
takes place at christmas
it just shows you there just haven't
been enough good christmas movies made
uh we could give it another shot
come up with something else or tweak
that one and and just another aside
about jeff goldblum
uh i i think this was something that i
just read on reddit as i was falling
asleep
jeff goldblum has this practice
whenever he meets somebody uh at a party
well the way it was described was in a
tweet from somebody who
was semi-famous like a journalist
and who would mingle at parties and he
would know some people at parties but he
was introduced to jeff goldblum for the
first time
and and and the guy
was introduced to jeff goldblum jeff
goldblum's first response was
oh my god of course
[Laughter]
and it makes you feel important and he
felt and he was like
i just didn't know how but i guess jeff
goldblum had read one of my articles or
something you know
he seemed to know me but then
i happened to hear him being introduced
to other people at the party and every
time he would say
oh my god of course you gotta love that
man
yeah i mean it's a little manipulative
but it makes you feel smarter
makes you feel good people wanna be
important if you're and i thought about
maybe i should do that or come up with
my own version of that and then i'm like
you know what you have to be jeff
goldblum well i just think you have to
change it
you have to be jeff god only change it
from what he says oh my god of course
but you have to change it um maybe that
was just that night
maybe when he's looking himself looking
at himself in the mirror before he goes
out he's like what is it tonight
oh my god of course and then he goes
well i think once you land on that one
you realize
it is the holy grail of introduction
responses
if you're jeff goldblum if you i mean or
someone else who
everybody at a party wants to talk to
like not he's not even just because he's
a celebrity because he's that
he's he's that he's jeff goldblum what
about yes finally
i mean i'm waiting to meet you you know
that that doesn't work because if you've
already met the person
it doesn't work oh my god of course is
the is the best but i'm just saying
i don't want to you don't want to
overuse it back to chris
you were saying something uh christmas
this year along with everything
else this year is is strained
and strange you know it's just
a lot of traditions are having to be
altered
because because the holiday season is is
is the time of tradition
but everything's you know everything's
got to change at least for me and my
household
we will not be going home for
thanksgiving or christmas
i actually think by the time this comes
out thanksgiving has already happened
yeah it has uh and i did not go home and
i'm not going home for
the uh the christmas holidays or new
year's or any of that stuff
uh and it's you know it's sad
so i'm i'm mourning the the ability to
do that i am really relieved
that my extended family
understands and actually even before we
told them i kind of felt like are we
breaking the news to them that
we're not coming home so but when we had
the discussions
it was like oh yeah we already knew that
you guys weren't going to be able to
come home
it's just yeah you know i don't want to
get into what the
what the what the covet numbers are like
now versus in a couple weeks from now
they'll be higher in a couple of weeks
but it's i mean it's heading in the
wrong direction right i've got loved
ones that i want to protect and i just
can't have
i i can't be the one that increases
their their their risk
i just can't have that on my conscience
i don't necessarily want to go here but
i will go here
uh because i know people feel
differently about this but it is just
a fact an indisputable fact that some
people
this holiday season will get on a plane
go across the country to be with their
loved ones
and someone will die because of that i i
i you know it's it's i'm not saying
right i'm i'm just saying that it's a
fact that's gonna happen you can do with
that what you will and so for for me
it's like
i can't that can't be on me i don't want
to be a part of that you know i think
next year is going to be different i
think we're going to be through this
i'm really i don't want to i don't want
i don't want the risk i'm just really
glad that
that they were expecting that they were
on the same page they were understanding
i mean that doesn't mean it's not it's
not going to be sad and it's it's going
to hurt
you know when new year's rolls around
and we still haven't seen anybody you
know
um it's going to hurt but but that's our
plan
the last two years i actually think
this will be the third year yeah so the
last two years you've been going home
things we've been going home for
thanksgiving and not christmas because
we
and i discussed this in this venue we
had made a point
that you know what we want to start
forging our
own swords traditions here
in in in our home base
so that you know i i've really started
to look forward
to what what when my kids
are coming back home for the holidays to
to me and christy
and then you know hopefully
at one point we've got grandkids coming
in it's like you know i
we want our home that we set up and the
traditions that we have to be the focal
point of
of this next layer of tradition you know
if we if you keep going home
it kind of stalls things out and that's
kind of the decision we made
so we give them thanksgiving and then we
don't give them christmas at least until
we can establish something
and that actually is part of the
complexion of this conversation i think
is this being the third year we've got
these covid complications
and limitations but still the neil
family we're trying to
forge what what christmas looks like for
us
um in california because you know
traditions and and habits and
expectations aren't formed in just
a year or two and we're only in year
three so we're still trying to figure
all that out
and then you factor in everything that
yeah you were talking about just in
terms of like
where where i'm at spiritually uh that
journey
and how all of that really
seems to come in a sharp focus
around christmas for for obvious jesus
as a baby
reason would you say that uh you hone in
on
those things did i say home no i'm just
saying that you said sharp focus
uh you're you're you're really the uh
the verbiage police today no either ah
you didn't say anything i'm just i just
throw it back it's a throwback to our
conversation i thought i said you did
not say hi
either um yeah and this and this
christmas
is gonna be uh especially interesting
because we're gonna spend it together
uh which we have not done you're talking
about us now me and you
uh as families we will be spending you
know i'm not saying that we're
necessarily going to get together on
christmas day
but we haven't made plans we don't know
exactly what the ins and outs of this
are but the family that my family is
going to
see is your family right and so
and that we haven't done that before
because we typically do go home to north
carolina for christmas and have
the traditions that we do with my family
and then with jesse's family
that all they all kind of live really
close to one another
and they do you know obviously they want
us to come back but they also probably
know that given our disposition
uh when it comes to the pandemic that we
will not be
and um yeah so this is gonna it's gonna
be strange because we haven't
we we don't have these traditions that
we've done
as a family on our own there's only been
one christmas
in all of our time in california where
we didn't go home
and you know it's like jessie's birthday
is a week before christmas
and then what we typically would do we
would celebrate her birthday and then
like that weekend before christmas
usually get on the plane go to north
carolina
so being here for the whole time and
then also usually we tack on like a trip
for ourselves as a family after we get
done with
the christmas and the new year's stuff
like right at the beginning of the year
and you've done this as well it might
just be me and jesse going somewhere
together like for a few days but none of
that's going to happen
there's just going to be a whole lot of
being at home
through this whole time and i really
don't know
how to prepare for it we'll make the
best of it at least we at least we do
have you know our families that we
were in this quarantine pod situation
and that that helps and then our friend
mike and his family were
you know we're we're gearing up
to make sure that like we're in we're in
a safe situation to pot up with them
i think i'm pretty sure they'll be here
for the holidays and so it'll be
like our three families yeah so i think
it'll be a good time
being being safe i'm looking forward to
trying to be a good team but we've got
to kind of
invent our i mean first of all i'm very
excited about
the food of course and i want to play an
integral part in the preparation of the
food i've got
several ideas oh yeah
that i'll actually get into when i do my
wreck later on but uh
i plan to feed you is what i'm saying
ultimately and um
i i could still contribute music
on a playlist yeah you can have a
playlist yeah great playlist
that that worked right yeah you know i
was able to you know whenever something
needed to be said
important i was a i stopped the music
yeah and then when it was over i started
the music back
and then people were like oh i like this
song you know it's like it's it's
just a little too loud can you turn it
out oh sure and while i was outside
frying up that chicken for the
the hot the nashville hot chicken
sandwiches
i was listening to the music outside as
well i had it pumping outside so i was
here in the playlist just by myself and
i was
kind of kind of i was kind of moving a
little bit you're kind of moving and
mike
brought me a couple of drinks which made
it
it made everything better yeah
there you go you know we all have our
part to play
um okay well now i'm just thinking about
my dress
you know might dress up like santa my
maybe could get
i don't know somebody could dress up
like santa well i kind of we could do a
nativity scene i feel like in our
in our pod that you know mike is
probably the
he's got the whitest beard he had the
whitest beard
uh we got this we'll talk about it
last year an elf last year when you guys
wanted to like so much with my
i'll do it with mike and uh mike's
family and jenny we um
we got matching christmas pajamas
we all wore matching christmas pajamas
well is that happening again
uh it should do i have to buy the same
pair that you already have or were you
going
all new uh i'd like to just reuse what i
have but i haven't thought about it
you gotta see if you can acquire it i'll
get something that's a close
approximation but a little bit better
but is there going to be a nativity
scene are we going to have like a
like a little baby jesus are we going to
have like goats and sheep
you know back home there was you you'd
go about you'd drive by a church and
they would have built this like
three-sided shack made out of like
pallet wood
and then there'd be people dressed up
like mary joseph and a baby
can there be a freaking hold on you've
been a part of a live nativity with me
i've not been a part of a live nativity
like been in it as a ch
as a as a youth group very very
young you weren't you joseph i could
have sworn that you were joseph i was a
shepherd
i may have been joseph one year early on
yeah
yeah it was cold i just remember it was
cold and i was like man i just got on
like
i don't remember don't have enough
clothes i thought it was inside see i'm
not even remembering this right there
was a live
nativity of boys creek first baptist
church that the youth
did and maria matthews was
mary i think that was a play and it was
inside
there was like a christmas cantata okay
well i
could have sworn there was a lot of
nativity there was no there was not a
real baby though i haven't done it as an
adult
because now i would be a an amazing
shepherd with my beard
you're too tall can't you no no no i'm
too tall for
joseph let's get let's get real here i'm
too tall for joseph that would be a
distraction but having one
tall ass shepherd or one tall ass wise
man i think you'd be a wise man because
they're they're
they're walking from a long distance
they're following that star
man i want to be the one with the
frankincense and
and if you want to be right about be the
merman the uh
the uh the the wise man is not gonna
show up for like
years right um he didn't show up that
when the baby was born
well now you're getting into some of the
maybe what let's look at some of the
complex questions around the
electricity of the nativity story let's
come back
we'll talk about in a second let's come
back to this uh we'll
talk about all that but first we do want
to let you know that whether you're
traveling or not
this christmas you can get a travel mug
look at this from mythical.com
it's tall it's cylindrical it fits in
any cup holder in your car
and travels with you you know you might
get excited about a travel mug
and you you wait for it to show up you
unbox it
you wash it or maybe you just put your
beverage in it you're like screw it i'm
just gonna drink it
that's my version of washing it and then
you put it in your car
and it won't fit in your cup holder not
with this one big fail
this thing will fit it's tall it's got a
nice
um secure top on it that that that pops
open
and it pops open in a way that you don't
have to touch the place where your lips
go
and it pops open in a way that it
doesn't um hit you in the nose when you
drink it yep
see that we thought through all this see
that it's nice now the
it's hard to read what it says but it
says good mythical morning but you knew
that anyway with rut and link
and maybe you like it that way
i like it that way mythical.com
get yourself a travel mug even if you
can't travel
um okay christmas i kind of
i kind of see this as for me and i i
mean i think for you
as well just because we you've been on
really similar journeys i mean there's
there's some different stages and of
course the first stage
is what christmas is like when you are a
christian
let's roll out just go if you have idea
of stages
just get roll out the stages just so we
i know where you're going okay stage one
is christmas
when you're a christian and and when i
say christian i mean a bible believing
in our case evangelical christian that
takes the christmas
story 100 literal truth
um that's stage one stage two
is a is a christian who is struggling
with doubt
engaging with christmas stage three
is someone who would no longer call
themselves a christian
engaging with christmas and you might
think isn't that the all three stages
i think for me there's a fourth stage
which is
well but you can maybe be suspenseful
about that there's a fourth there's a
fourth stage okay
i'm not gonna say yeah i'm just gonna
say it's the way that i am hoping to
engage with christmas now
um which may be surprising i'm very
interested in this you know i think
in anticipation this conversation a
number of thoughts come up for me
some of which i don't want to process
here honestly because
i don't want this to be the first place
that i process this type of thing
because it implies inviting people to uh
to weigh in or or help me figure things
out for myself and i just you know
i'm making the decision that i'm trying
to put some boundaries on what i'm
processing publicly and privately
uh and so some of that's coming up here
um
but i'm but i'm still very excited to
talk about this and you know we
we tend to we tend to approach these
type of things and think about them in
different ways if you look back at our
deconstruction stories
uh they're they're they're unique to to
each of us in the way that
um that we've we've grappled with our
faith and that we've moved forward in
our journeys
i take great comfort in the fact that we
that we are moving forward in our
journeys and that we
have different approaches i really enjoy
the fact that like
like i haven't thought about these
stages that you just mentioned so i'm
kind of
um but i have my own thoughts that i'll
i'll pepper in there and
might choose to keep my mouth shut at
other times but we'll see we'll see how
it plays out
and i do anytime we talk about and we
are you know we we talk about spiritual
things more freely
since breaking the seal with our
conversation earlier in the year about
our spiritual deconstruction
um and these are sensitive topics that
mean
a lot to a lot of people people hold
these things very near and dear to their
hearts
for obvious reasons and so just
disclaimer as we talk about these things
i just want to be very clear that
nothing that i'm gonna say
uh or i'll speak for link as well it's
meant to be
prescriptive this isn't not advice this
isn't how we think you should approach
christmas this isn't what we think is
right for you
this is our process this is just our
personal story
of what it was like at those different
stages
um we're probably you may relate to some
of it you may not you may disagree with
some of the conclusions
i that's i'm not trying to to get you to
come to a different conclusion it's just
this is a story
that applies to every conversation we
have here but with a sense of topic like
this i'm glad that yeah i feel like
because it's like we're literally just
processing
our lives in this venue well sometimes
we do give
prescriptive advice to people if they if
they ask for it sometimes if they don't
ask for it
but it's usually about things that don't
really matter if
right that's the most if we can help it
um so we're gonna stay a little cagey
yeah so but but but honest
okay so again for what is probably still
remains to be the majority of
of the life that i've lived so far i was
uh an evangelical christian
you know someone who believes that the
bible
is the inerrant that means without error
word of god and so that means that the
christmas story itself
um you know of god taking the form
of a baby human uh
of of a virgin becoming pregnant with
that baby human
and that baby human being god himself
and also god's son in the form of jesus
coming to the earth to offer a pathway
of
reconciling people to god that's what we
thought
and we thought uh that's what christmas
is for an evangelical christian it
is the story of jesus's birth and is it
jesus's or is it jesus birth
i've heard pastors say it both ways
don't get hung up
i'm going to say jesus's just because
because you can tell that i'm saying
it's possessive the story of jesus's
birth
um and i think it's just an interesting
thing
in our culture in america i guess this
happens in other places but
you know there's like this long-standing
thing that happens between like
there's the merry christmas people and
there's the happy holidays people and
there's like
this battle line that's drawn and like
people get mad at starbucks if they
don't say merry christmas or whatever
right
and this is a relatively recent sort of
cultural battle
but i remember uh
what i can relate to about this is
i remember as a christian and listen a
christian who was like working for a
christian organization full-time like
taking it very seriously
i always thought that this little
cultural
infighting about the whole merry
christmas thing i was like why are you
all getting so upset about this
yeah i mean i didn't i've never related
to it i think another way that we might
have put it was because i agree
that that was my assessment of times
like this is not a good look this is not
this is not the [ __ ] this is not the
battle though yeah
what is your desired outcome from this
battle that some atheist somewhere would
say yes you're right
merry christmas i i think is that what
we're trying to accomplish
it just felt it felt like a turf war
like protecting
your turf and again i was like very much
on board for jesus is the reason for the
season
because it rhymes it looks great in a
store window
yeah we uh a couple of months ago we
were we were driving past this
uh all my family was in the car and we
drove past uh
i guess it was october and uh an
automobile lot
and you know they got the showroom with
like the big glass windows and
they paint all their windshields with
prices but they painted
their showroom windows huge
across all the windows like if you if
you had to really take the time to
to back up or really take in the whole
thing across the whole thing he said
jesus is the reason for the season and
then it was october they had never taken
it down
so i'm like well well kids you know what
it's fall
jesus is the reason this is the reason
for falling and technically that's true
you know i mean from that perspective
so yeah so we didn't really get in on
that bandwagon
and to me it felt silly uh when i when i
saw christians getting really concerned
about that particular issue
even though for us personally
jesus was absolutely the center
of of christmas which was the main
holiday that
that we were personally celebrating yeah
and well in the way that i related
there are other holidays that are
happening around them that other people
celebrate
uh you know so to say happy holidays
just
to acknowledge that other people are
celebrating other holidays
is is not a bad thing that's just called
being considerate
right it seems very christian actually
so
so i just never got that i'm i'm glad i
mean there's lots of things i'm like i
wish i would have done it differently
but i never
i never fought that fight yeah but the
thing that never insisted that somebody
else celebrate something that i'm
celebrating right right
but the thing that i can relate to when
it comes to this uh
maybe holding christmas in a precious
way
is the secular treatment of
of christmas just traditionally right so
you've got um
like okay you've got charles dickens as
an example right so
you've got a christmas carol or any
really anything that centers around
the spirit of christmas as it relates to
anything other than jesus so you've got
santa
and gift giving and well gift-giving
you could say that the tree some people
say the tree is paking some people say
the
tree is christian some people say you
can [ __ ] it you can commandeer all these
things for
your in your individual purposes but
what i'm saying is that like
i'm not saying i wasn't one of these
anti-santa
christians either and not in like a
santa is just
satan rearranged in the same letters
right like there are christians who
think that and think that santa is this
secular distraction i didn't think that
either but what i did think
is when i would see a christmas movie
let's say elf as an example your
favorite movie best movie ever
i could appreciate how awesome of a
movie it is not necessarily my favorite
or even in my top 10 but a very solid
christmas movie
i could appreciate it and appreciate all
the good principles that it kind of
uh that it reinforced in the spirit of
christmas
but as a christian i would kind of stand
aside and say
yeah that's a real nice story but you
guys do know that jesus
is the reason for the season that the
whole point of this holiday is to
celebrate the fact that god became a
human
came down on our level and gave us a way
to be reconciled to him you do
understand that's what it's about well
and it's one thing to imply it in all of
the
the hollywood christmas movies but i
mean a lot of times it's blatantly
stated that you know the reason for the
season or
they may put it in different terms but
they'll blatantly say that like the
spirit of christmas
is family it's it's like good tidings
right it's just you know it's it's
i'll be home for christmas is getting
together it's just it
it's that type of stuff and i didn't
want people to change their movies
i wasn't thinking like you know elf
would have been a whole lot better
if like you know if the what's the elf's
name you should know this
will ferrell well what's his name in the
body if
buddy would have become a christian
during the movie like i'm not talking
about like
i'm not saying i want to have like kirk
cameron type movies
yeah i wasn't into that no no no we
hated those who
hated those movies we hated movies that
were explicitly christian and had
but but because they weren't artful yeah
most
because again i felt like it was for the
it was for the audience
but anyway um all right it was preaching
to the choir whatever
but i still had this sort of judgment in
my mind that was like
yeah you guys almost get it but you
don't
really get it you've created all this uh
holiday accoutrement
around christmas in order to make it
seem meaningful but you've missed the
heart
of it which is this is about jesus y'all
and so it's all pointless ultimately
you know if you're gonna miss the heart
of it then
all this stuff around it really doesn't
mean anything i was very sensitive to
putting
my values in expectations on to other
people that i didn't think
i had any realistic expectation that
that they would be interested in that
um but i'll tell you what i did do
yeah i mean as a kid
our evangelical upbringing was like
the center point of our identity i mean
and then
uh i i think for me there had to be like
looking down my nose at other people or
just or maybe feeling sorry
for people who are just missing like the
the the real the real
point of what needs to be celebrated at
christmas and what i'm experiencing is
celebrating it was more of a bless their
hearts
yeah there was a depth in in the
experience that i was having
that i felt like by comparison like from
the
from my evangelical perspective looking
at other people
just thinking okay it's just a bit it's
a bit
shallow yeah i mean like
family and and love and service and
all these good things are they're very
meaningful things but
they're not as meaningful as god coming
to earth
humbling himself as a baby like that
that's tremendously inspirational
and uh and a lot of other things
and then when when chris and i got
married and we we started having kids
it's like okay now is my opportunity to
you know i'm in charge of creating new
traditions and finding the ways that
we're going to keep jesus at the center
of of of of our focus
and i so one of the things we did is
we would we
we made up our mind that we were gonna
always tell our kids that
and maybe we need to put a spoiler alert
on this but i don't know what i'm about
to
say if there's somebody listening that
you don't want to you don't want to know
certain things that
about the about the man uh the secular
man
of christmas yeah we're going to reveal
the truth about the secular man of
christmas so if you have little ones who
are listening in on this conversation
and you want the miracle of christmas to
remain alive
tune out right now this this what
happening right here was never a problem
for me because
i decided i think this was a link
decision
it's like you know what our kids are
always going to know that
santa is just is fake but we're still
going to have
we there's we're still going to surprise
him with presents
on christmas morning that weren't
wrapped in under the tree there's going
to be some unwrapped stuff that's going
to be there when they run down the
stairs and
you know i still want to have that scene
because that's it's so exciting and i
don't want to take that away in time but
when the weatherman is like we've
spotted santa on the radar
yeah my thoughts when lily's five years
old she
she she never thought there was never a
point where she thought
and she knew that she wasn't supposed to
tell other kids
and unlike you who told me way too late
in my experience that santa claus was
fake
uh she did not do that to her friends
well then the funny thing about this is
that i never made a decision
one way or the other uh i always you
know me i like
making things up making my kids believe
things that aren't true just for my own
personal entertainment
and um so santa it fits the bill there
right and so
we would you're saying it probably was
real crazy well the thing is
is that he's got three eyes but one of
them has an ipad but think about my kids
though my kids are just like me
and i didn't you know the reason i
didn't think santa was real when i was a
kid wasn't because an adult told me it
was big
you're saying you're smarter than me as
a kid well no i just think i think about
things in a different way let's just say
that
i was like this can't be real and i
embrace the wonder of
and joy of life and so i don't question
it my kids did the exact same thing
there was never a moment where i had to
break a truth to them
it was more just like at some point at
our early age they were just like i know
santa's not real i know you're giving me
these gifts i had made it but it's fun
to play along
i'd made a decision to actually
proactively tell them and like
burst the bubble before it would hurt
too bad but
the reason why i actually felt really
good
about saying this is a protection from
even for my kids at their youngest age
i'm removing some of the temptation
to focus on the wrong thing it's like
remember
we're focusing on jesus here we can have
the presence and we're
you know the reason why we have the
presence is because uh
presents were brought to jesus because
people knew
that he was he was god incarnate and
they were they came to worship him
as a king and they gave him gifts and so
you know you just try to couch
everything
through the lens of jesus right that's a
christmas movie for kirk cameron
right through the lens of jesus uh and i
felt good about that
now you know well and i don't feel bad
about it now
but i just you know i was a i was kind
of a stickler
and but i remember feeling like this is
something tangible that i've done
that impacts my family's ability to
focus on what matters most well and
sometimes i think that that's
that's that was my role and some people
might say just another reason if you if
this is your
perspective uh another reason to clarify
the fact that santa is a made-up thing
is because you don't want it to be like
all right there's two things that are
true
child uh jesus is god's son
and god in the flesh this christmas
story
but also there's this dude named saint
nicholas who comes and
flies around hauled by reindeer and
gives you presents flying reindeer
at some point i'm going to break the
news to you that one of these
two things is not real and the way i'm
going to do it is by saying
one of these is not real you choose
right yeah no but you don't
yeah and so it for i think for some
christians it's like hey let's just
let's tell our kids the truth and again
this is the truth according to
a christian um that hey this story is
real and this story is sort of the
secular
cultural story that we tell ourselves
with that's a fairy tale like the
like the tooth fairy whatever easter
bunny you know and
i they never believe the easter bunny or
the tooth fairy really either
for the for kind of the same reason
easter bunny easter bunny is simple
thing that was like you know what
i don't want i don't want to have to
break it to my kids that i was lying to
him
but i don't know that that's how kids
process it and i never went there
because a lot of my kids all the time
but the easter bunny
is the worst holiday mascot because what
does the easter bunny
do i mean the tooth fairy has a very
specific thing it's a transactional
relationship
you know you give him at the tooth he
gives you money i understand how that
works i know when it happens are you
picturing the rock or something
and he well i'm saying he because i
played the tooth fairy
in uh a very a video i'm very proud of
do you remember that video that we made
i can't remember what it's called about
the difference by the differences
whatever
uh but the easter bunny no one
says hey let's go outside and find the
eggs that the easter bunny hid
we even we do away with that mirage we
say no the parents are going outside and
what
what is the role of the easter bunny uh
i think to be
eating this chocolate i don't know yeah
it's a it's a weak-ass
weak-ass holiday mascot i will say there
was another
factor in saying that santa claus wasn't
real but they still got the gifts
because then i could take full credit
for all of the gifts
i understand i think that was an
ulterior motive on my on my behalf
but yeah there was there was this i mean
i was
we had so many family to visit that we
didn't go to the christmas eve service
we didn't actually have a lot of
like christmas time traditions
um but we did have some like we were we
would read
like from the children's bible like the
christmas story
from a young age um i've got this video
of lily
um before she could read
she we had read it to her so much that
she had memorized the christmas story
based on this
children's picture book and it was it's
the cutest thing because she would act
like she's reading
but she just memorized everything that
we said per page
and it you know it felt good to know
that
one of the first things she memorized
was the story
of of jesus humbling himself
and coming to earth in order to be her
savior
and you know it's it i just felt like i
was
okay it was like this is this is my job
as dad
and chrissy's job as mom is is to
instill this knowledge
in in her at at a young age
to to where she knows that god loves her
and cares about her
and went to great lengths to
to not only demonstrate that but to make
that to make that relationship
possible you know so it felt really good
and it was it was validating that
you know we've got this system i've got
this belief system that i'm
i'm all in with and i'm very
every benefit associated with it like i
was i felt like i was
at the time that i was only experiencing
the benefits you know i think i've
processed
in my other story that like there's
another side to it
for for me but um at christmas time
it felt good it's like okay we're not
losing sight of the point
yeah um
we most of our most of our uh touch
points related to
church you know we were very involved in
our in our church you were very involved
in your church as well but during
christmas we were very involved in
church including like the
you know being involved in the program
to the point where
every year jesus jesus jesse my wife
would
would play mary in this like play where
and i think maybe
for the first year she did it or one
year she did it that one like
locke was jesus but other years it was
other people's babies like a real baby
she would sing huh like you know she's
like this one woman show as
mary and you would you'd like candles
and it would be a it would be a big
moment you know and then
and then there was that album that dude
what is his name is it uh
is it andrew peterson is that his name i
don't know if that's the
i don't know i don't know if there's
this guy
you know he he he uh this the it's the
christian
musician who came out with the album
that has become the all the songs that
christians play
uh it's been like 15 years ago and it's
just like
um it's not married did you know
that's the old school this is like it's
the one about
like mary in the the whole album is a
christmas album and it's the one where
like all the things that people sing
evangelical churches come from and i
think his name is peterson you know
these songs for 100
sure since you were a music leader at
your church you just didn't maybe not
make the connection to the album i
wasn't that hip
um i assume they're still i know they're
still playing him because when i went to
a christmas eve service at my
old church like two years ago he's still
playing
but what is your what is your point i'm
just saying that that was just a
complete sidebar but my point is is that
all our touch points were
related to like the christmas eve
service and um
the things leading up to uh christmas
that we did as a church and it was all
very meaningful and it was all very
personal
and impactful and our we were involved
as a family
um but let's move on to stage two right
because as we've established
uh that mentality and that approach did
not continue for me
you know i struggled with doubt pretty
much my entire adult life as it related
to my christian faith but
uh you know probably about 15 years ago
or so
was when the doubts began to get
uh kind of crippling to the point that
engaging in like
bible reading as an example would
inflame my doubts right so if i would go
to the bible to
have my doubts addressed some of the
other things that i had read
about these particular things would
enter my mind and it became this thing
where
the more sensational the story the more
difficult it was for me to believe
and i feel like the christmas story kind
of brings together a lot of different
elements right so you've got some
things that are let's just be honest
difficult to believe
virgin birth the idea that there is a
star
that is settling over the town of
bethlehem that is leading
the wise men to the town which seems to
indicate that the
the the authors didn't really understand
the nature of stars and how far away
they actually are and how that's not how
stars work
um or maybe it was a special star that
was just happened for this i i
listen everything that i'm going to say
right now which is where
is sort of like my doubts that i have
about the story
i am well aware that uh there are
plenty of evangelical traditional
christian explanations for all these
things
i'm not discounting those i'm just
saying that for me
when i engage with the christmas story
from a historical perspective and some
of the issues that there are there
you know related to like this the herod
and the
governor of syria quite herineus
or the census and these things that like
you can kind of call into question from
a
historical perspective in the way that
they line up or the fact that
the the christmas story the nativity
story is kind of added
to um
you know luke and matthew but it's not
in the earliest gospel
the book of mark so it kind of lends
itself to this idea that
the legend of jesus was growing as time
went by and so they were adding things
like hey we got let's add this story
that shows how he fulfilled prophecy
again this is the secular view of these
things
and i began to see some of those answers
and some of those explanations to those
difficult passages less as
a good answer and more as what felt like
this seems more desperate right this
does it's not satisfying to me
and so when i would engage with the
story
i would be thinking about all those
things it's like i'm thinking about
the the critical view of this story
which is not a fun way to engage with a
story right
and so christmas became
a time where i was kind of of two minds
right there was some serious cognitive
dissonance going on because there was a
real appreciation for the idea
of christmas and the idea that god would
become
one of us and would make that connection
in a way that i had not seen
demonstrated in any other faith system
right um
and there was all the stuff that went
along with it and those songs that we
sing from that album that i can't
remember
they were incredibly meaningful even in
the middle of my severe doubt about
these things when i would read the story
and these doubts would be inflamed i
could still
move on to singing the song singing the
hymns thinking about jesus
and it would be very moving and very
impactful
but there was a few a good number of
years there
where the doubts were so strong that
engaging
with the story of christmas was a bit of
a train wreck inside my
my mind yeah i am
i i can't understand what you're saying
i think in my process
christmas didn't bring up as much but uh
it didn't
you know it wasn't as difficult because
there was more
like the traditions that we had and the
amount of family we had to visit it was
easier to get distracted
and i felt like i tended to focus on
the expectations i had placed on myself
to make sure that like
we were remembering that jesus is the
center of this and we're doing some
things and we do have some
we do we have the advent calendar and we
have
traditions that we're doing with the
kids um
but it was easy personally i think as
they were starting to be doubts for it
for me just to go into distraction mode
because there was so much else going on
anyway
uh in terms of gifts and family and food
and everything else that
is the secular reasons for the season
that everybody falls back on
right um i i definitely remember you
talking about albums
at a certain point when i was i mean our
conversations were
pretty constant and so my
you know i was more resistant at first
because i didn't want to shake things up
but as
as i started to come to grips with my
own doubts and my own
experience i remember at christmas time
i would i would listen to sufian stevens
christmas albums like for a couple of
years he would release
one every year so there's like this four
disc box set that
as a family it's still very much a
tradition for us to listen
this is the album that's playing in our
house constantly
and uh i would recommend getting it if
you're a fan of
sufian's earlier stuff his stuff now i
can't get it it's like
i tried to get i don't know what you
need to be under the influence of but
well it just went it went it's very
electric it went electronic and i'm just
not into that so this like acoustic
homemade it feels like
four track in his own house like playing
horns and
having people who can't sing start to
sing along with him and like yeah it was
awesome
uh it's really awesome but i remember
like thinking okay if
sufjan he's a he's singing these
christmas songs because
you know he's he's got a christian faith
i don't know his story
but like he's got this faith in jesus
and
you know i i don't know i'm not gonna
put a label on him i don't know what
label he applies to himself if any
or how that's changed over the years but
you know he made
he released meaningful christmas music
that was
that was meaningful to me and i thought
this guy
you know i he he seems really
progressive he's an
artist he's cool like i think maybe this
is my future this is maybe
maybe there's something in his
relationship with christmas and with
jesus
that like i could be like i could take a
cue from sufjan stevens
you know it's uh it's it's well it's
interesting it's like i don't
i'm not gonna read as many books as you
i'm just gonna start listening to this
guy and start saying
well you know the thing about music
though i think this is an interesting
point and i agree with it and it's in it
and relate to it personally because
music kind of transcends um
the intellectual doubts that you might
have you know and you're dealing with
the stuff that's kind of up here
in your your head space and is this a
rational sort of battle that's happening
your music connects with your soul
in in a different way that this is why i
can still listen
even today don't consider myself a
christian
i can listen to uh you know be thou my
vision
one of my favorite hymns and tear it cry
you know what i'm saying like um
so i yeah there's something that
transcends that mental barrier
in music anyway so i think that was and
i think it keeps
honestly it keeps people around for
longer
you know there's something about uh
there's something about
just singing together i mean what other
venue do you have in your life where you
go
and you get together with a bunch of
like-minded people and you sing songs
that are just
the most passionate things you could
possibly imagine i mean that doesn't
happen
christians got that one down pretty good
um
you know i mean the closest thing that i
can think of is when we went to a
to our friend's house and we did the
sing-along um
last year you know did you oh you didn't
even come to that
you guys didn't come but well you
totally missed out man thank you
um but like we just sang we it was like
singing together i was like man
singing that was a thanksgiving thing i
think singing together
with other people it's just something
that should happen
in more places you know but anyway i
digress
so so there was there was that um
that period where there was that
cognitive dissonance happening and it
was just like i can't engage with this
but
i love my family and i still love god
and i'm trying to figure all this stuff
out
um and then there was
again i i told the story i don't
remember the exact
year it was more it was after we moved
out here when it became like
official but still more than several
years ago
where i was like okay it's official i
don't i don't believe this
anymore like i just i cannot
i cannot honestly call myself a
christian i'm not going to
pursue this i'm not going to engage with
this i'm not going to go to church
anymore
you know it wasn't that clean but there
was a point in which that was
who i became but you still got christmas
rolling around every single year right
and it's weird it's weird when you
have like hey we've been doing this
every year and it's been
just saturated in meaning
it's been saturated in the most
uh sort of consequential
and important meaning that it could
possibly have
and now you're just going to become one
of those guys that's just
getting through the christmas season on
some good tidings
from the christmas movies for somebody
who's had a really
deep spiritual experience
um those christmas movies again elf
great movie
doesn't cut it it it if you've had that
depth of experience
yeah god is not a character will pharaoh
is awesome but he is not god
and so it's like you come to that time
and there's this like man the depth of
experience
in the depth that this that this had
associated with it
that permeated my life personally but
also permeated the lives of my
wives and children why why
watch out my wife and children
our family that's the easier way to say
it it's not there
yeah how do you engage with that i think
about
the realization that that children's
book that we had
you know it's like one one one year you
pull down the christmas decorations and
the christmas books and like that book
that lily memorized
that you read with lincoln some when he
was younger
um that like you realize that like
it's you can't find it in the box
anymore or i don't remember
ever deciding to not pull it out of the
box or not to read it to lando but it's
like
yeah it's just kind of like you realize
you know what
i orlando never read this book or you
know and i remember
i i think i do remember christy finding
it and reading it to lando
at a young age and it was like it wasn't
this communal experience that it was
before because we were in this
transitional time
and again it just it kind of the
christmas season
brought it into focus and
you know part of it is well you look at
all the other there's still a lot to be
distracted by
and we're still you know we're still
going home for christmas and you know
there's a lot of logistics involved and
it was once we moved out here
so it
it it didn't feel like this painful
moment
it was just like all of a sudden you
realize that book's not coming out of
the box anymore
you know um
and i do think for me
and that still even now
like i'm i'm at a different phase than i
was that was like
everything seemed to be changing much
more rapidly in terms of my
worldview and my my belief paradigm
in my allegiance to the evangelical
worldview
you know that you get to a point it's
like you come to grips with that's not
that's not me anymore and it's not
changing as fast but
there's still this residual in the back
of my
mind i think um
i i i guess i would just call it there's
there's a there's an experience of guilt
it's like because there's this question
it's like when you let
as you put it in in your story you you
jump ship
you let go of something but you don't
have anything specific to grasp onto
it's like i'm not
we're not now you know
ascribing to some other religious belief
system
well and i and and and but so
i i do think for for me there is a bit
of
yeah it's like oh did we did i make the
right decision does
did we as a family make the right
decision you know it's like there's
these little questions it's like i
you know i've tried my my best to
embrace uncertainty as
as a positive but there's still moments
of struggle and i think it it
it happens more around the holidays when
you realize that like something that was
extremely meaningful
and a practice that you have with your
with your first child
is not part of what happens with your
third child and are
are they missing out you know is is
you know have we done them a disservice
and then i have to i kind of have to
rederive what bro
what brought me to this point and also
look at our children
and how tremendously fabulous they
are and how proud i am of them and start
to
just have this reality check that like
okay these feelings of guilt
uh or obligation sometimes i i think
i i would describe it as i'm feeling
judged by my former self
uh because the position i'm in now and
the way that i interact with christmas
um is something that again
i said earlier i would feel i'd feel
sorry
for people that they didn't have the
depth of experience that i have
and now i'm in that position
yeah and i mean i definitely relate to
that i mean
[Music]
i don't uh guilt it's not really my
that's not my thing
as much oh it's my thing but there is a
um
i'm not blaming it all on evangelicalism
either it's it's a link thing
not it yeah it wasn't created by the
church
it was just how exacerbated by it yeah i
think that the
really what you're getting at is your
one of the things you're doing is you're
highlighting the importance of
religion right you're in you're
highlighting the importance of a
spiritual life
and so uh because if that meaning
is to be had from something
if you can if you can find that meaning
and that purpose
in something well that's one of the
reasons that
religion exists that's one of the really
that's the main reason that people
stick around for it even if they don't
quite
believe it in full right if they have
some doubts they're like but the
alternative
is just i don't believe anything and i
do interesting that you bring up that
that quote from my deconstruction story
where i talked about jumping ship
and it was a very dramatic line and it
has been played in many different videos
that critiqued our construction
deconstruction stories
um there's a there's one of my favorites
is one
uh speaking of kurt cameron by mr ray
comfort
who works with uh who who works with
kirk
and um he kind of goes through
and and and breaks down our story and
plays some very sentimental music and
almost some like music that's sort of
like
impending doom the whole time as we tell
our stories and
a lot many things are taken out of
context it's very entertaining but
um one of the things is that line about
i jumped ship
and i took my wife and my children with
me and it's just like that people quote
like it's so sad he took his wife and
his children with me
i think i regret saying
it was it was a little bit of a dramatic
thing to say i regret saying it because
it
i think the the better analogy is i
jumped out of a ship
and there's not another ship like that
that you're jumping into
right but it doesn't mean that you've
that you're there you have no meaning
you have no purpose and you have no
principles in your life those those
things are still intact
the source and if you're drying you're
drowning yeah the source and the
philosophical foundation of those things
is coming from a different place and it
may be a place that you as a christian
philosopher may say
is you know illegitimate i would
disagree
i'm just saying that like it isn't like
i've been swimming in this ocean of
uncertainty
and my family's going nuts it's like but
that's how
it was interpreted but i
i do i mean i agree with what you're
saying
in in the sense that it's like all right
you approach this
and there's there's there's the puzzle
pieces are in place
like every time you come around to
christmas it's just like we have a
puzzle we know where the pieces go we
can tell our kids this is how it works
and then all of a sudden you come to the
you come to the holiday and it's like
the puzzle
doesn't can't fit together in a very
satisfying way anymore
and so the central assertion was don't
forget what matters most yeah
that was that was our experience in
phase one yeah
and then in in the in the doubting phase
well now we're we're talking about phase
three now we're still in phase three
okay phase three of you know what
that i i haven't replaced that matters
most
with something else specifically but
we're still you know we're just getting
through this
and uh honestly well i'm not suffering
my family's not suffering we're not um
it's not a horrible experience but
you're hearing the echoes there's the
old
hearing echoes yes there is no meaning
here
this is pointless you know the things
that we would have thought about people
who weren't christians before when we
were
christians and you find yourself in it
and you're like man i you know
like i still really love my wife i still
really love my
family i i we stand for
very similar things we're not different
people but
we don't know how to reconcile this
story
in the same way and so you find yourself
becoming
the secular person that you
felt sorry for and you're like i guess
about the food the decorations i'm
getting through christmas on the
accoutrements
service and and family and
love but in an effort to transition into
stage four which is
uh which i don't like saying stage four
because it sounds like cancer
uh uh you know uh phase four
um i actually
personally again this is not
prescriptive i'm not saying this for
anybody else this is for me
i actually do find phase three to be
inadequate for me personally
so the idea that christmas is
just about those things just about the
give the giving and the receiving and
the
uh the good tidings and great joy
unrelated to jesus
just the secular side of things just
watching elf or seeing tim allen be
santa again
i do find those things to be inadequate
like i don't
i didn't want to be stuck at phase three
in other words i didn't want to become
a completely
uh non-spiritual person
who was like that's all just mumbo jumbo
and i'm going to just build my life on
rationality
completely and it's just a natural
existence and that's it and that's
now people a lot of people have done
that more power to you if that works for
you for me
and by the way people have converted to
other religions and then they have
this so then they have new holidays that
they don't have to
to come to grips with christmas on other
terms they have other holidays that are
in place of it that
have depth of meaning that but they're
not as good as christmas
i'm just kidding um
but you know something interesting has
happened to me
um and i think i mean it's been happened
over the past few years this is not
super new
but when we broke the seal earlier this
year
boy when we were telling those stories
about our deconstruction we had no idea
what the hell 2020 was going to bring
we had no idea that people were going to
no longer care about our deconstruction
story
as soon as they found out about covet
19.
maybe it was a blessing
from that perspective it's not a
blessing for the world by any means
um but
we had a really interesting i'm using
the word interesting a lot and i hate
the word interesting so i apologize
um we had a unique perspective
um on
the way that we would approach our past
faith for
the bulk of our career right we're kind
of a like a little bit embarrassment
about
how serious we were and how far we went
in and the fact that we were
missionaries
i mean not necessarily embarrassment but
like this is going to be difficult to
explain and i'm going to say where i'm
at now
and so there was almost an avoidance a
secrecy
i'm sure some of you have been fans for
a long time could sense that
like oh they don't talk about their past
and i think that it actually influenced
the way that i dealt with it personally
it it inhibited my own personal freedom
to explore spiritual things because i
had such a weird relationship with it
and i was this public figure
that had this past that i kind of
couldn't explain and didn't want to go
into the details of
but when we made the decision to tell
the story in its entirety without
apology
it broke a seal for me personally
and it what it did is it kind of
it was like something within me got the
okay
to be like all right you can move on now
you don't have to be in this place
that's just a guy who used to be a
christian
and doesn't believe that stuff anymore
and that's who you are
you can actually move forward to
whatever's next for you from a spiritual
perspective
and one of the things that has happened
and
this is i don't know where
i don't know exactly where it's all
going spiritually for me
but i said him when i told my story that
i had an openness and i did
i have an openness i did and i ha and i
do currently have an openness towards
um spiritual things and one of the
interesting things that
interesting again one of the things that
has happened
is sort of a re-engaging with the person
of jesus
in a completely different way and that
is
you know i used to think about
anything that if i go to the bible and i
would read something that jesus said
again
i was sort of overwhelmed with well let
me let's bring in the critical lens
let's bring in the perspective of the
jesus seminar onto this text
that's not a fun way to interact with
jesus right
or a particularly useful way personally
when it comes to like your own personal
edification
there's been a couple of good books
that i've read this year that i'm not
going to go into
but have sort of changed my perspective
on how i can
engage with jesus not as
someone who is the
in is god in the flesh
that is the only way to be reconciled
with a vengeful god who who has to
punish somebody you know
the i i'm not holding on to any of the
any to
the old stuff but just looking at what
jesus said and did as a spiritual
teacher
and being like there's there's a lot
there right
uh in even engaging in the story
the christmas story not with a
preoccupation about whether or not it's
historically true
or or based in fact but is there truth
there
to be gleaned is there something that
you and your family
can actually get from interacting with
it taking it at face value
without getting into this game of trying
to figure out whether it's real or not
which is a little bit ironic because if
you think about the stories that jesus i
mean first of all jesus taught
in parable right he taught in story he
told
stories he made analogies and
the fact that no one is ever recorded in
the bible as responding
to one of the stories that he told with
but did that really happen okay yeah
no one was like but hold on hold on dude
this thing with the samaritan did
did that really happen did it happen
last week did you see it happen
because if you didn't see it happen i
don't believe it
his point was is that truth
is not i think i
truth is not something that is just
contained in
this factually historical
um verifiable
vessel right truth comes in
a lot of different forms and i can
listen to
i can i can watch a movie right i can
watch a movie that
is from beginning to end fiction and
still find truth in it
and i'm not listen i'm not saying okay
the only way i can engage with the
christmas story is by just saying it's a
fairy tale and that's it
but i'm saying that if i quit if i turn
that part of my brain off
that is just constantly trying to judge
whether or not jesus actually said this
or whether or not this actually happened
whether or not somebody was a virgin and
got pregnant and i'm just like
let's set those things aside because i'm
not going to reconcile those things
i i mean i have a very strong opinion
about some of those things
and some very strong doubts but is there
a story to be heard there is there a
lesson to be learned there is there
truth
within this um
and i think that that is very freeing
for me personally
does that translate into like something
going into stocking
i mean what practic is there is there a
practical
there doesn't have to be for like
christmas and and
and maybe this is
maybe my question is revealing about my
own issue which i can get into but
so maybe it's not a fair question but do
you even think about it that way
like no so are you really are you saying
for at christmas time you're reflecting
on the story
but you're you're doing it in a way that
it can be edifying
to you your interaction with jesus can
be edifying for you
as opposed to it being something you're
trying to judge or tear something down
yeah because because you're either
you're either not going to interact with
jesus at christmas time
or you're going to have a a negative
interaction or now you're trying to
say i'm i'm going to have the positive
interaction that i'm able to have
and i i'm actually i've i'm at a point
where i can have that
right and that's what i'm going to have
and well and i think some people would
say
guys this is where this is
this is where the enlightenment screwed
things up because if you go back to
pre-enlightenment
in pre-sort of modern thinking about
things and pre-rational thought about
things
uh this is how people engaged with the
stories of jesus there was not a
preoccupation with whether or not these
things happened or not it wasn't
there wasn't this tendency to want to
verify
and completely wrap your mind around
these things but there was a spiritual
interaction with them
and i believe that there are still many
christians who would say hey guys this
is
this is what my faith looks like right
now yeah
um i i guess it's it that
my old mindset creeps in because it's
like you know the way i interact with it
was
god became human in order to save us
from ourselves even that okay so it's
right so
when we look at the story of christmas
from a christian
perspective um you're right
it's god emptying himself
becoming a baby again i don't know how
this works
i don't actually believe that's what was
happening but according to the story
becomes
becomes a baby becomes sort of the
the complete 100 percent god 100 human
that then is the only sacrifice that can
be made in order to reconcile
everyone who will call on the name of
the lord
to god right but isn't there a different
way
to isn't there something else to
appreciate without have that having to
be true
right for instance because since you
mentioned this exact thing
because i was thinking about this
earlier
i don't know the nature of god i don't
necessarily know
anyone can understand grasp or know
or talk about in a understandable way
the nature of god i think that there are
if there is a god um
there's probably an experience of that
god is
is somewhat ineffable meaning you cannot
communicate it in a way that would make
sense because it's happening in a
different place on a different level in
a different way
than human language can express
but the idea that god
would want to be so close
and so involved and so much a part of
humanity
that he would become one of us
is a beautiful concept that makes me
think about the nature of god
in an open and edifying way does that
make sense
it doesn't have to have happened as
described
for me to be like that in the way i'm
glad we talked about music it wasn't
that i didn't know this was gonna happen
but
a song resonates with you it's there's
something about soul level there's
something about
music that you connect with and you
wouldn't say that song is true
and that song is false but you would be
like this song
i feel like i begin to actually
resonate and synchronize with this music
because it connects with my soul and
this
doesn't i feel like that can happen with
a story
as well and so for me there are elements
of that idea
because i mean if anything if the the
concept of god being
in everything and god being available
within
someone and the idea you know
the universe the fabric of the universe
being whatever you want to call it
that's something that's still very
intriguing to me that i want to be open
to and i want to lean into and i feel
like i can find that in the story of
christmas that's all i'm saying
i think our former selves would be
saying right now
i mean you just can't you can't invent
you can't just invent the terms with
which you interact with jesus
i mean you're miss you know it's you're
kind of you're missing the point
you're just inventing a new way to
interact with jesus
that is just picking and choosing what
you want that's going to be
inspirational for you
i think that's what i what our former
selves
whatever um but i don't think
and if it doesn't matter what anybody's
saying i think
for you you're making a decision because
i
i do think the decision has been is is
it going to be any interaction with
jesus
you know or am i just going to move on
and and say that was in my past
you know having being spiritually open
i i think is i i hear
you that's what i see and what you're
saying that like you're choosing to
uh to approach jesus
in a way that you can and
who is anybody to argue with that even
if they think you may be missing the
point or doing it wrong
well you know it's think about close
encounters of the third kind let's keep
going with this music thing i'm really
glad you brought it up because
i don't know if you've seen the movie
you've seen the movie i've heard about
it i've seen
images from it so the way that they
communicate
with the alien beings is in the form of
music because music
again represents this ineffable thing
that's happening
on a different level of consciousness
uh that the language barrier between
whatever they would
speak and whatever we would speak can
can't but we find music and that's how
we communicate
right i think that's a beautiful picture
because i do want to address
the criticism that the our former cells
would make of course my former self
would be like dude you're just a new age
bullshitter
that just does whatever thinks whatever
he wants to and there's
there is absolutely nothing that i can
say
to convince that per who per person who
thinks that
that that's not what's happening but
what i would tell my former
former self is that i think that there
is a
preoccupation with categorizing
and systematizing
the deepest truths of the universe
in a way to make them understandable and
applicable
and there is some merit in that
but what i'm trying to be open to is the
idea
that whatever god is
can be something that i can experience
without having to turn around and
explain it
and categorize it and be able to
recreate it and package it and write it
down
and speak it to someone else
and i think that um
ironically i think that some of the
things that jesus said when you
when you kind of come to some of the
things that he said from a fresh
perspective
seemed to indicate that he was hinting
at some of those things along with a lot
of other religious leaders who've
lived and said similar things the buddha
being one
ultimately what i'm saying is i have
found it to be
especially free freeing
take that uh post enlightenment
human has to figure everything out hat
off
and be like what is it like to engage
with god in the way that i would
engage with the ocean you know i don't
go into the ocean
and ride a wave and preoccupy myself
with the physics of what's happening
i just do it i just experience it
right and
i think if there is a god that god is
probably like that
and so when i think about the christmas
story yes it
is something that somebody wrote down
2000 years ago yes it is something that
does get down into
some very particular truths about
things but what is it like to
read a story that has that kind of
significance and that kind of staying
power
and read it from a fresh perspective
with taking that hat off
what kind of new things will you see
well
one thing you'll see is you know okay
i'm looking at mary and joseph in a
different way i'm thinking about the
fact that this is a pregnant woman
who isn't married who is seeking refuge
how relevant is that in the world that
we're in right now
that draws out my empathy not only for
them but for people who might be
currently in our world in our society
dealing with the same things
and i don't have to just
focus on the but is this
the son of god period
does that does that make sense yeah i
can find new things in it
yeah so i you know i i definitely see
how as you describe
this phase for you that it's it's
how you're practically approaching the
spiritual openness that
that we both talked about at the end of
our stories
you know so you know i i appreciate
hearing it as
it's food for thought for me um as i
continue to uh
to aim for spiritual openness myself um
because that that is important to me i
think when when you describe your
your tendency to want to judge
the bible
and like going against that tendency in
order to
move towards openness and
you know a spiritual experience
uh for me i think
i think the task that i'm work that i'm
working
with is it's judgment as well but it's a
it's a judgment of myself
um and i you know i'm i'm on a journey
that's i think that's where i'm at in my
journey i think a lot of it comes up at
christmas that i've alluded to that like
it's it's uh
trying to trying to move past
self-judgment
because that's how that's
you know that's how i that was my
interaction
a lot of my interaction with with with
with how i came up
right so it's it's it's shedding that
judgment so that i can actually have
um an open and
honest uh spiritual pursuit
and i and you know i'll leave it at that
at this point but i think that that's
uh that's where i'm at you know again
i'm
i'm very grateful to be where i'm at i'm
very
i'm happy to be on this journey i'm not
i'm not i don't feel that i'm failing or
or struggling i i don't have a
tremendous amount
of of i'm not battling with doubt you
know just because
those questions come up around christmas
time again
uh i would not characterize it that way
but it's you know i i'm constantly i
i want to be answering the question and
continuing to make positive progress in
my in in my spiritual journey
um and so part of that is
it is shedding the self-judgment and
understanding
uh when that comes into play
and and kind of putting that in its
place yeah because it's not i mean it's
not easy it's not
i don't have the same exact hang-ups but
it's not easy for me right because
i feel like i
stagnated for quite some time and it was
it's weird that it took us talking about
it for me to
be like hey i can pick up a richard rohr
book you know
and read it and know that you know we
don't exactly agree on everything
but the way he talks about jesus
is again it resonates
and if i remove that that judgment that
that okay well but i got to figure out
how this lines up with this this system
no i don't i don't have to figure that
out
and who is god who am i to think that
god has to be categorized
or even understood you know and so
i don't know i don't i can't
i can't turn around and tell you
what you and you being anyone listening
what you should do because i can't tell
you me what i should do
it's a disposition right it's a it's a
leaning
in an openness more so than it is a this
is the prescribed path
and it just feels very different and i'm
sorry if when i get into it when i the
things i say don't make sense
but i kind of feel like that's the point
right the closer
the closer i get to it the more i can't
talk about it
okay well and we don't have to talk
about anymore right now
so uh i mean if that's
if that's your fault that's the phase
that's it that we've gone through
maybe there's another phase who knows
man phase five
okay let us know a recommendation i do
uh before we
wrap that conversation up though just
let us know uh you know your experience
in where whatever phase you're currently
in
uh and hashtag how you think about
christmas and the holidays
i do have a wreck and
i may have talked about this at some
point but the website that i use for a
lot of my
meat tips amazingribs.com
it's not really a left turn because it
goes back to
i really want to do like a standing rib
roast
uh because i think that's
amazingribs.com that's uh
meathead it's meathead meathead goldwyn
i guess is his name and he this dude is
just
the authority when it comes to barbecue
and again it's amazing ribs because he
started i guess with telling people how
to make ribs but it it runs the gamut
you want to know how to
you know smoke bake brine a turkey
whatever
any kind of piece of meat you want to
know exactly how you should do it from a
scientific standpoint
i mean he has like a a chemist or
somebody that he consults like a local
professor who
goes into the details of like this is a
myth you don't need to do this but you
do need to do this and here's why you
need to do it and so for someone who
wants to appreciate sort of the
technical side of making mary with meat
um it's it's a lifesaver and he has
incredible recipes and i'm hoping
to follow at least one of them for
christmas
and you will be the receiver of that
bounty
yes amazingribs.com
merry christmas merry christmas to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of your biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best